dave uh two dollars you guys gamma
degenerates unsolved i love dave
uh jackie rose 20 thank you jack you
can't wait for my shirt to get here so i
can represent the degenerate gamma
spergs i love
thank you jackie fructose corn just
donated 420
no comment but thank you so much uh we
do appreciate it and somebody in the
chat says and i'm sorry i scrolled by
and i missed it but somebody says
uh you know voxday is an unlockable
character in the new mortal kombat game
well what you have to understand this
if scorpion
is attempting to or sub-zero is
attempting to freeze me solid
that takes a combination of buttons
if you are to waste your time in
like a point fighter attempting to
freeze me into a solid block of ice i
will simply
hit up forward front kick
come downward and i will block the ice
did you know liu kang was a point
fighter
that bicycle kick i mean clearly
if you see kung lao throwing a razor
bladed hat at you
that would in any normal situation
get a man disqualified in any normal
point fight
you simply cannot
shoot electricity out of your fingertips
at an opponent in a martial arts
exhibition
it's always fun when we get to turn the
wheel i i find it fun just
throw some of the spurs off of here oh
[ __ ] uh
question tale says uh videos from the
cut are degenerate not
sex oh videos from the cut are
degenerate not
okay sorry yeah you're right that's
degenerate you're right
sorry i will never use it again what you
have to understand is that having four
arms would slow you down significantly
in a fight
it would make you less effective and you
would require much more core strength
i would grab coro's fingers and i would
just rip them apart
it would be funnier if he just reviewed
video games though
what you have to understand is is that
if you
hold down and just tap low kick
over and over again um you will uh
generate an electrical field
that will make it impossible braden told
me that i'm the only person that was
quicker than scorpion
now you see me now you don't
[ __ ] stupid fox vox is my new
favorite
yeah vox day is actually quan chi
oh man [ __ ] sorry [ __ ] teddy beal
don't play videos from the cut it's the
generous
or they do like a mortality yeah where
he just starts talking to them and they
fall asleep and die
a poor immortality you [ __ ]
reads one of his books they kill
themselves
they use their own fatality on
themselves scorpion rips his own head
out
uh you're uh you're a gamma uh you're uh
you don't under it really is amazing to
me you you do really you do really nail
the vox day he does a two one hour show
and he says three things
also you know we're going to be
interested to hear
what you guys want to learn about
because
you know one thing that's a little bit
difficult this is the barcelona
guy that we played the video yesterday
yeah there he is that's the big tv show
coming up [ __ ] what is it undisturbed
what is it underscore this [ __ ] guy
if he does not look like a private
investigator
like if if he kept showing up in
different parts of the same cruise as
you
all weekend wouldn't you start getting a
little jumpy you'd be like are the feds
following me or something
he also looks like he should be eating
like roaches and stuff around the
country
you know what was that dude's name that
zimmerman guy that would go around and
eat wacky food
but he just looks like the kind of guy
that conspicuously has like a brand new
flowered shirt and white hat on and he's
like
reading a paper right down like right
down the buffet line from you and you're
like
hey do you look man you've been [ __ ]
looking at me all weekend what is his
ex-wife
is it my job who's it is it the workers
comp board what is it
just tell me somebody said i guess vox
did get on joe rogan
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] nicole uh and i
and i can say this in terms of um
you know she wants to come in
that's funny um why is that funny
the they're quite good um i was a little
skeptical
i'm a little skeptical you're telling me
pal
harley's kind of militant about the
priority does all he owns
black t-shirts from the louis ck
collection yeah i was going to say the
riggy gervais collection but yes
it's the same collection yeah it's the
same collection they just they just
changed the tags in europe yeah it's
ricky i'm not as i'm not as uh
convinced but it is good stuff so
what a shitty painting dude what about i
think somebody said he was on vacation
so this was like in a hotel room or an
apartment or something
oh i see i didn't realize uh yeah that
really look like an
airbnb picture yeah
they will go get the cheapest little
generic pieces to throw up and go well
it looks like
it's art yes that's all right we'll just
address that here
and you're banned for life
box you're a 40-something year old man
you're you're a father
always fun
see as a dual citizen us eu
what kind of uh
what kind of careers can you suggest for
someone looking at moving
so he doesn't even like put together a
show play because i really i don't watch
fox day i'll be honest with you
he doesn't put together like a show plan
or like hey we're going to talk about
this today and that he kind of just
treats the chat i get yes that's what
all these guys do now
like so that's all he just does he just
reads the chat like we always have
[ __ ] like even when honest like when we
see when we literally
go like wow we have literally nothing
today
that means that we still have more than
enough to do one show with
it's just thin very thin like our idea
of
we have nothing for today is
[ __ ] once we do one more show we've got
nothing but like these guys don't front
load anything they have nothing loaded
in the chamber they just go live and
talk it's like [ __ ] man they're just
super confident like i i'm
one of those guys if i have like last
night i had plenty of stuff but it's all
a lot of it's monetized stuff so i'm
doing it on my
my new friday night waves where i don't
i'm just not gonna monetize it
but um yeah i'm like [ __ ] doing that
i'm like and i'm like [ __ ] man i've only
got like
still we had more than enough to do a
show but me and royce get panicky
like if we're like oh [ __ ] i'm gonna do
two hour show with
with this but yeah they just one thing
they just go one topic